monsieur Bruel je peux savoir ce que
alors là il y a le téléphone il y a le
clignotant qui n'a pas été mis ça fait
deux choses d'accord monsieur Bruel
alors je veux bien qu'on soit connu
qu'on soit une célébrité mais ça
n'excuse pas tout d'accord monsieur
Bruel
quoi
les réseaux sociaux on filme les gens à
leur insu on leur manque de respect on
veut faire le buzz pour rien et ne vous
trompez pas le mec en a rien à [ __ ] de
la sécurité routière tout ce qui veut se
payer Patrick Bruel pour faire des vues
sur Tik Tok ou sur Instagram donc c'est
des franchement et bravo hier qui m'a
dit qu'après ça il avait vraiment envie
de se casser la voix
dans mes bravo à lui d'avoir gardé son
calme parce que je pense qu'il y en a
d'autres qui auraient pété un câble
franchement c'est possible non mais
Patrick
après on peut pas cautionner le
téléphone au volant bien sûr c'est relou
c'est une galère on voit les gens ils
roulent n'importe comment il roule dans
tous les sens c'est super dangereux mais
d'où le mec se prend pour le procureur
ou un flic ou je ne sais quoi pour lui
peut-être que si ça se trouve le mec qui
est en scooter derrière il s'est fait
barrer la route par Bruel qui est en
train de téléphoner ça l'a agacé on a
pas de la montre d'accord mais ça c'est
le quotidien malheureusement c'est le
quotidien des scooters partout dans
toutes les villes ils se font barrer les
routes parce que les mecs ils ouvrent
les portières parce qu'il déboîtent sans
clignotant portable ou pas portable les
gens ne mettent pas leurs clignotants
portable vous avez déjà déboîté son
clignotant non il faut mettre
[Rires]
vraiment peur en scooter il a pas le
temps d'avoir la présence d'esprit de
sortir son téléphone de filmer après à
ce moment-là je trouve que ça c'est
comme ça je pense qu'il est d'accord
avec le motard moi je pense plutôt que
le gars voulu faire une darkaïa
voilà pourquoi agressif pourquoi
il le porte
[Musique]
il est pris en otage non il me fait ça
le mec en filmer comme toi il est pris
en otage moi il me fume comme ça je
descends il a raison
les mecs des fois ils font des demi-tour
ils s'arrête au milieu de la rue je
pense qu'on va faire une caméra cachée
il me bloque en camion je suis descendu
l'autre fois je me suis en vrai que le
mec le mec il me fait ah ça y est tu as
attrapé la grosse tête tu es connu j'ai
mabrouilles
agressif
en chauffeur j'ai quand même un truc à
dire
mais les mecs quand tu es en chauff
comme toi qui sont en plein milieu qu'on
a rien à [ __ ] et qui dit moi je
travaille et moi je fais quoi je vais à
Disney à 9h du matin derrière
pourquoi ils sont pas mieux je fais des
connards qui sont mis sur la livraison
mais comme toi qui se mettent sur les
places de bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
vite croire qu'on se lève le matin pour
se faire sauf que les mecs les mecs de
la chance de me balader avec également
voilà
une fourgonnette qui peut enlever les
voitures donc voilà donc quand il y a
quelqu'un la voiture voilà est enlevé
c'est tout voilà terminé c'est génial
mais les mecs comme ça il ment parce que
je suis d'accord avec lui il se mette
pas sur le jeu d'accord
c'est un ami et puis hein parce que
c'est un ami oh il y a une caméra vous
allez du côté du chauffeur-livreur du
manuel et pas de l'intellectuel eh voilà
intellectuel il est où parce que là je
le vois pas hein attendez l'intellectuel
c'est vous oui
mais pour TPMP ça passe
vous avez une américaine à côté vous
avez Delphine vous savez Géraldine
maillet et puis vous avez les autres
comme moi tous les matins tu les verras
pas les chats
sans compter que celui qui fait il filme
aussi donc il a pris son téléphone donc
il est au volant il est aussi son
téléphone
il est meilleur enquêteur qui Maurice
vraiment vraiment vraiment
commercial les deux roues sont trottoir
le moteur tournant j'étais en train
d'appeler ma fille ils m'ont arrêté vous
êtes au volant je suis arrêté j'ai les
feux de détresse et je suis arrêté je
suis monté sur le trottoir trois ans
avant de récupérer les points
téléphone portable c'est 3 ans avant de
récupérer les points en fait j'ai
décroché avec
et moi je suis pas vraiment d'accord
avec vous parce que je pense que si
jamais Bruel l'avait pas bien pris et
vous me dites si jamais ça vous arrive à
vous vous ne le prendriez pas bien non
et là tu dis vas-y qu'est-ce que oui
mais je pense pas franchement si
réponse
et là ça lui pose après un problème
énorme
c'est sûr voilà
c'est sûr
voilà vous le savez c'est tout voilà
comme ça au moins les gens le savent et
après il y a pas un truc quoi comme ça
moi je préfère dire les choses
j'ai des problèmes d'agressivité
le garçon a un problème voilà je moi je
dis tous les spectateurs je m'en fous
voilà comme ça au moins ils le savent un
gars voilà et voilà c'est tout il y a eu
un problème avec les il y a un mollar
qui est parti après on a rigolé voilà
c'est tout